All right, so this isn't a recording of
a call, but I felt like this is
something I should put into this
category of the server.
Being that I've gone over auction market
theory and profiles, I want to go over
how I use
yearly through weekly VWAP in the same
way. So, essentially,
>> [snorts]
>> you know, auction market theory and
whatnot applies exactly the same way to
a VWAP as it does a profile. So, if you
look at a profile, right, you have
you know, your distribution, you have
value area low, value area high, and you
have the point of control, which is the
mean.
And if you look at VWAP, it's actually
exactly the same.
Right? So, this is your point of
control, which is VWAP, the mean,
and one standard deviation either side
of the mean, so here and here
is your value area high and value area
low.
Um so, why is that important? Well, it's
you have both a developing value, right?
So, as price moves, right, this is
monthly VWAP, for example,
it's going to develop, right? And it's
going to move with price.
And that goes the same for really any
VWAP, but, you know, in this case, I'm
talking yearly through weekly.
And, like I said, you can apply that
principle of auction market theory. So,
you know, is price rotational in value?
Did they recently accept back inside? If
so, you're going to expect the move or,
you know, the 80% rule can be applied,
and you should expect traversal of
value,
or, you know, first target is the mean,
which is VWAP, right? You can apply all
of those things, right? And when you use
this kind of top-down analysis way of
using yearly all the way through
weekly,
right, it gives you a really good read
on, you know, where there is, you know,
confluence, right? So, do weekly and
monthly agree with each other? Do does
yearly disagree with
monthly or quarterly, rather? Like, you
know, any combination of that, right?
And then you kind of filter that
information down and come up with a uh
you know, hypo on the day or the week,
whatever it happens to be, right? And
then you use these in conjunction with
profiles.
And you know, very simply, right? When
the periodicity ends, so for example,
this is the week,
right? When when you have the prior week
ending, you know, I have on my indicator
it plots a box for me. So, not only do
you have
the developing week, which is here.
Here's developing Vwap,
developing week value area high,
developing week value area low.
You have previous week value area high,
previous week Vwap, and previous week
value. Right? So, between
developing and previous value from
yearly through weekly, I believe you
have 24 levels to use. Right? So, it
gives you a really good
both dynamic, right? Or developing, and
static value area to work with. Right?
So,
if we just look at Bitcoin, you can get
a really good idea of how price is
interacting. So, if I break down this
range, right? And you know, this really
becomes useful when you use it with
profiles.
Right? Use it with composite structure,
volume profile, that kind of thing.
So, for example here, right? Let's zoom
back, and I'll just go over some
interactions here. So,
genuinely
Sorry, generally speaking,
um yearly through quarterly is going to
be harder to use.
Right? It's going to be less accurate.
It's not going to give as good of
interactions as weekly and monthly.
Well, weekly and monthly are, you know,
generally very accurate, and you can
trade off of them much easier.
When you're using
yearly or quarterly, you know, they can
be very important, but they're a lot
harder to base trade off of, if you want
to look at it that way.
So, yearly right now isn't important,
although I could go over and show you,
you know, price
relative to yearly, right? So,
this is prior year now, but this was
2025 value, right? We know we're we're
imbalanced down, we're rejecting value,
we accept back into value, right? So,
you would apply the 80% rule expecting
reversal,
and then we're imbalanced up on value,
so value area high developing year value
area high is now support, and it's
supported till proven otherwise, right?
You start to shift back inside.
We've now proven acceptance back inside
of developing year.
First target is the mean, which is VWAP.
We bounce there for a little bit, and
then once that's lost, it's a very easy
flush down to
the VAL. So, that's the full traversal,
right? But, nonetheless,
yearly is not important right now, being
that yearly and quarterly are the same
value because we're only in February on
the year. So, not important.
But, I'll just go over a couple
scenarios where you could have used
these together, right? So,
you know, here, for example,
this was Let's talk about this week.
This was last week's high, I believe.
Where is that?
Oh, that is right here. Okay. So, again,
there's a few different values you can
use here. So, it's it's not the idea
that you're only using developing value,
only using prior value, whatever it
happens to be. You use all of them
together and just see where things agree
with each other essentially at the end
of the day.
>> [snorts]
>> So, if we look at the bigger picture
here, right? Let's just say we'll go
back to February 6th. So, basically
right here, February 6th, right? So, you
have
developing week value, developing month
value, and you have developing quarter
value. Right? So,
this is when we got the big flush down
into 60K, right? We found a bottom down
here. We shift back inside of developing
week value. We shift back inside of
developing month value.
So, what do you do? Well, you apply that
80% rule, right? You expect traversal up
to value area high. So, at the time,
these are both very similar levels, but
nonetheless, it doesn't matter.
Um the kind of one exception to that
rule is, you know, you can tag the mean,
which is the VWAP in this instance, and
that can interrupt the move, and, you
know, it can come down and retest the
level and then move. It can come down
and break the level,
right? There's there's no right or
wrong, but nonetheless, the the mean, so
the POC or the VWAP here, can stop that
move.
Right? So, you can see
you get the acceptance here, right? So,
you're expecting traversal. Of course,
here's the mean reversion, right? So,
now price is just bouncing around VWAP,
right? Initially breaks down,
comes back for it again. It's still
really just bouncing around view up.
Just slightly kind of deviated it,
right? This is where other confluence
comes into play. So, composites and
whatnot.
Uh and it's exactly the same with the
monthly, right? So, you see the
acceptance there capping upside against
the mean, which is view up. Again, same
thing, view up.
So, it hasn't shown any acceptance
actually higher, right? No time and
space above this level. Really, it's
it's just slightly chopping, just barely
deviating it, right? And it's over the
weekend.
So,
you know, as that gets built out,
developing quarter is also
coming down. With that being said,
right? The the
the same rules apply, right? So,
you know, when you are, you know, we're
imbalanced up, right? So, now developing
quarter value area high is going to be
support until you see acceptance, right?
So, there's your acceptance.
There's your traversal, and then that is
now support, right?
So, same thing, imbalanced up,
acceptance back inside, traversal. And
then now that you're outside of value,
developing
quarter value area low is going to be
resistance
unless it gets back inside, right? And
then you get the move, then it's going
to be support until proven otherwise.
So, really this entire flush down,
right? Price is rejecting val, right?
Rejecting it here, can't shift back
inside, can't shift back inside, massive
flush, right? So, now it's imbalanced
down on quarterly value is what I refer
to that as.
So, upon this sweep, right? Like I said,
now that it's imbalanced down, it's
bearish against quarterly value, right?
You anticipate this to be resistance,
you know, unless you get time and space
above the level, right? And maybe prove
acceptance, right? But again, uh context
matters. It doesn't make sense that it
would happen here.
But nonetheless, right?
If you look at structure here,
right? You have 1 2 3 4. You have five
sets of high. So, you have four highs
here in your range, right? Price is just
rotational at this point. Again, I'm not
even going to look at composite
structure here.
Um
so, you get a sweep of the highs here,
right? Big excess on this wick. So, you
take out all of these highs and it
trades right back into the range.
And at the time that it did that, it
also tested quarterly value
quarterly value area low, I should say.
As resistance and rejected it, right?
And then you get the breakdown from
there.
Um and then, you know, from there,
right? That that's just more confluence
that this is going to be resistance and
it's going to be a level it's going to
have trouble breaking being that we're
bearish against quarterly value.
And then from there, right? You can
probably infer now that, "Okay, if we do
start to break down from
uh weekly view up and monthly view up,
the the next logical target is going to
be
weekly val and monthly val."
So, at that point, it's now previous
week val, right? Because now we have a
developing week.
And then from there, right? It starts to
develop rotational acceptance, mean
reversion, then starts to break down
here.
Even retests it before coming back down
to previous week val. And again, that
would be the same kind of imbalance
pullback or rejection as this move here,
right? Being that price is away from
val.
So, you're expecting that to be
resistance unless it accepts in, of
course.
Uh again, context matters. So, again,
rejecting developing val, rejecting
developing val.
And then at that point, like I said,
there there is your
reversion back down to
value area low, right?
There's there and then we got a sweep
lower, so swept that low and then we get
the move back up.
So, very similarly, you can see how
those interactions are working together.
Um right? So,
capped upside against previous week view
up at that point, right? Then you get
the move back down, it sweeps it.
And then it's also developing month. And
then what's the next target? Well,
you you mean you can use them both
together, right? You just see where
things overlap. So,
from there you get the move back up into
previous week view up, which is also
developing monthly view up right and we
kept upside there again.
And then again you just apply the same
rules. So now we're just rotational
in the lower half of developing month,
right? So if you split it in half,
right?
You have the mean here.
You have the standard deviation either
side of the mean.
We are completely rotational, right?
Just ping ponging between view up and
valve in developing month and previous
week is also the same, yes.
You can see how these interactions work
together. Again, there's a whole system
around this that we use.
Uh but nonetheless wanted to touch on
that.
Um and even more interactions here,
right? So we kind of filled in this
single print here, tagged
developing week view up
around that level, right? We actually
came back up
and we got a big push up here. We failed
at previous week value area high.
Right? So knowing that, what's the next
obvious target? Well, you expect
reversal down to the low.
Right?
And at the same time, we also capped
upside against monthly view up. So the
mean. So rotational in the lower half,
we just tagged the mean with a good
reaction. So what's the next logical
target? Probably valve.
Right? So you're getting
you are, you know, again we're
rotational in the lower half of
developing month value, right? We kept
upside of view up so you expect reversal
down to the low and we kept upside
against value area high of previous
weeks. Now you expect reversal. So
rotational in the lower half and just
rotational in general, now expect
reversal.
And you can see that's what happened
here.
Right? Previous week valve, previous
week view up, previous week value area
high
and we just moved back down to
previous week valve.
So
just something I felt like throwing in
there. Very, very useful. You can apply
all of the rules
that you apply to a volume profile or
composite structure to both prior and
developing view up.